good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in early 2009 more than
12 years ago the obama administration
made a surprisingly
probably unprecedented accusation
against westchester county new york a
pretty liberal place
according to the obama administration
westchester was an instrument of white
supremacy not the good liberals who live
in westchester bill and hillary clinton
alexandria
cosby cortes many others no one accused
them of being bigots
the problem was the buildings they lived
in
all those single-family homes row upon
leafy row
set back from the street well-tended
lawns mailboxes
those were all examples of racism
literally structural
racism and the only solution the obama
people
announced was much greater density more
subsidized housing complexes in
westchester more high-rise apartment
buildings
maybe some drug-addicted vagrants living
on the sidewalk begging for change
only if westchester county became more
like the bronx could it become
non-racist well this was all something
of a surprise to the people who live
in westchester again most of whom are
dutiful liberals
they didn't realize they had a white
supremacy problem
between 2000 and 2010 for example
according to the census numbers
westchester's black and hispanic
population had risen by more than 50
percent
so how could the county be racist it
didn't seem to make any sense
in court the obama administration
explained their reasoning
they singled out westchester's practice
of standard
zoning that referred to county
regulations that restricted the height
of certain buildings
and limited the placement of sewers to
protect the drinking water it sounds
reasonable
but according to the obama
administration those were restrictive
practices
restrictive practices as a legal term
under civil rights law
means they were racist and because they
were racist the obama administration
withheld more than
20 million dollars in federal funds from
westchester county
if the county wanted the money it would
have to construct 10
000 low-income high-density very
non-racist departments
so this battle it didn't get a lot of
news coverage but it went on for all
eight
years of the obama administration and in
the end to its credit
westchester fought back because they
could afford good lawyers
and they eventually won in court but
many places couldn't afford good lawyers
they're not as rich as westchester so
they had to relent
under pressure from federal ideologues
communities in oregon and minneapolis
for example with very little news
coverage
abolished single family zoning this all
happened in recent years
the question is why is it happening the
goal isn't to
eliminate racism the goal is to
eliminate
suburbs so rather than improve the lives
of people who live in crappy places the
idea is to
destroy the lives of people who live in
nice places
why would you want to do that why would
you want to eliminate the suburbs
well there's a very clear political
reason suburbs are typically
purple politically republicans can win
just as democrats can
but if your goal is to make the country
a one-party state you'd want to change
this
you want to make suburbs into cities and
if you did that you'd win
every time democrats win cities
of the 10 biggest cities in the united
states democrats run nine of them of the
50 biggest they control
two-thirds it doesn't mean they're good
at running cities they're not many of
our cities are on the verge of collapse
people are running away from them
but making cities better is hardly the
point winning elections
is the point democrats are happy to
admit this here's congresswoman ayanna
presley of massachusetts from yesterday
watch this is about human and physical
infrastructure
progressives in congress have been
leading this fight
care economy is infrastructure climate
justice is
infrastructure housing justice is
infrastructure
transit public transit justice is
infrastructure
and so these bold investments must be
made to support
workers and families in order for us to
have
a just equitable and robust recovery
from this pandemic
housing justice it sounds like a term
that maybe iona presley just made up
what does that mean well if most people
were asked they would say it means
you're not allowed to prevent people
regardless of what they look like or
where they from
from moving into a specific neighborhood
and that's true that's been federal law
for a long time more than 50 years you
can't discriminate
in housing sales and you shouldn't be
able to but that's not what she's
talking about she's talking about
something very different she's saying if
neighborhoods look
different then by definition they're
racist
if one is nicer than the other you have
to make it less nice
or else that's not equity the obama
administration was on this early in 2015
the department of housing and urban
development under obama
issued a final rule on what it called
affirmatively furthering fair housing
now according to the hud secretary of
the time julian castro
the fair housing rule was simply
intended to enforce the fair housing act
of 1968 the law that makes it illegal to
discriminate in housing sales
or in renting on the basis of race again
that law has been on the book
a long time and it's not controversial
but that law also requires local
jurisdictions that receive
federal money to take steps to
affirmatively
further the goal of eliminating race
discrimination in housing
huh this is a complex
word play but here's what it means under
the obama administration
hud went one important step further
according to julian
castro the existence of quote
concentrated poverty in urban centers as
opposed to the suburbs constituted
de facto evidence of racial
discrimination in other words
as long as there is a place that's
poorer than the place you live
the place you live is racist
that's insane but on the basis of that
assumption
they move forward and local
jurisdictions were told to eliminate
single family zoning and increase
density
in business districts and if they didn't
comply they might lose millions of
dollars
in community development block grants
from hud
that was a very radical step and most
americans were unaware it was even
happening
and people who live outside the cities
are very against it including faithful
democrats
none of them were for that if they
wanted to live next to section 8 housing
they would have stayed in the city in
the first place
so people hate this idea suburbs are
very complicated organisms like
everything humans build
they've developed over a century in some
cases more than a century
for good reason to have federal
ideologues came in and destroy them
is very threatening to people they're
not for that again
even democratic voters are not for that
and of course joe biden understands that
he's not a genius but he knows what
people fear
so when asked about it during the last
campaign he lied
watch biden reassure you that it's
racist even to suggest
that he would want to change america's
suburbs here it is
look what he's doing now the president
he's trying to scare because an awful
lot of suburbanites are now deciding
they're going to vote for me
at least the polling data suggests as
opposed to him and he's talking about
you know biden's going to what he's
going to do he's going to send all these
folks out to suburbia
they're going to end up with houses out
in suburbia and apartments in suburbia
yeah well a lot of suburban voters did
vote for joe biden partly on the basis
of that
claim that he wasn't going to send a lot
of people to the suburbs but that was a
complete lie
now joe biden is preparing to do just
that
now at the time his defense was that the
hud rule by itself was not enough to
restructure and eliminate suburbs
local communities that didn't want to
comply with the rule could simply refuse
hud grants they'd lose millions of
dollars of course
but they could survive what biden didn't
say
is that the hud rule was just the first
step in his new
infrastructure plan which you can read
online and you should
biden calls for dramatically expanding
the federal government's power
over suburbs the plan calls for
implementing the provisions of something
called the home act
that was a bill first proposed by cory
booker of newark who is a lunatic and
reckless
that legislation goes much farther than
anything the obama administration even
attempted
it would cut billions of dollars of
federal funding to any local government
with quote
ordinances that ban apartment buildings
from certain residential areas or set a
minimum
lot size for a single family home
so you under this law if you're a town
are no longer in charge of how long of
how large your lot sizes can be you have
no
control over anything what's the point
of having a local government at that
point
but it goes farther the home act doesn't
simply cut off hud funding to suburbs
that don't comply
with its equity rules it prevents states
from getting federal transportation
grants of any kind
if they refuse to allow high-rise
apartments or other high-density zoning
in their suburbs and that's very
different unlike a hud grant that is
money that states
have to have they can't refuse it states
need federal transportation dollars
to fix their streets and highways and by
the way it is their money anyway
it was dutifully sent to washington it
is every year by citizens of their
states
but the administration is in no mood for
negotiation with suburban homeowners
screw them
with their decent schools and crime-free
streets
living in their little 1950s america
according to the principles of equity
those people must be bigots by
definition
they're living better than people who
live in densely populated cities are
living
therefore we must crush them
this is not a conspiracy theory very
soon it could be the law
read the bill abolishing the suburbs is
a major part of the bide
administration's
infrastructure plan that legislation is
still being negotiated tonight and it's
not
final but already the media are rushing
to defend it what
shills they are what liars here's usa
today for example usa today the nation's
largest
quote newspaper quote biden's proposal
would award grants and tax credits to
cities that change
zoning laws to bolster more equitable
access to affordable housing
a house with a white picket fence and a
big backyard for a fourth of july
barbecue
may be a staple of the american dream
but experts and local politicians
say multi-family zoning is key
to combating climate change racial
injustice
and the nation's growing affordable
housing crisis
really because if you wanted to fix the
affordable housing crisis maybe you
would prevent
foreign governments from buying up
residential housing stock which they are
doing
or blackrock from buying up
single-family homes and turning them
into rentals
maybe you would make some effort to
loosen the housing market a little bit
but they're not doing that they're doing
just the opposite
so you may ask yourself can the federal
government really ban you from having a
suburban home
with a backyard celebrating the fourth
of july with your kids all the name of
climate change and racial equity
can they prevent suburbs from having
roads if they don't build low income
housing projects
well under existing civil rights law a
plan like this only works if the feds
can prove that your roads are somehow
racist
and that is exactly the case they've
been making right out in the open
why has nobody noticed this it's not
just the obama administration that says
roads and buildings are racist pete but
a judge
is now saying it too watch this the
interstate system was built to keep
certain groups in and certain groups out
so it was built on a racist system
correct
yeah often this wasn't just a an act of
neglect often
this was a conscious choice there is
racism physically built into some of our
highways
eisenhower's interstate highway system
is now racist
really i-95 is route 5 is racist
tell us how pete but a judge does he
even believe that no
no one believes that just like nobody
believes that westchester county is
bigoted because it has rules about where
you can put a sewer drain
it's not about racism stop with that
it's about power
for democrats the goal of this
infrastructure plan is permanent control
over the federal government
and for multinational corporations like
blackrock the point is driving down the
costs of homes even further
and building more apartment high-rises
in the suburbs
that has been the goal of the most
powerful people in the world for some
time
in fact just a few years ago it was 2016
that the world economic forum released a
video explaining and we're quoting
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
what's less clear is why more
self-described conservatives their job
is to conserve things like america's
self-respecting independent middle class
aren't objecting to this it's not that
they even notice it's happening
they're negotiating this bill the future
of the way americans
live is at stake and you never hear them
say that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else